[Musik]
liepen heute gibt es mal ein trend der
durch tik tok und instagram läuft ohne
ende wir machen nämlich dass sie brad
von domino's ich hab letztens erst davon
erfahren ich habe meiner freundin sarah
die hat auch instagram sales account
also said i als mögliche position da
schreibe ich euch mal in die infobox und
sie hat gesagt mach das unbedingt nach
der schmelze lecker und am gleichen
abend war ich mit meiner familie und da
sagt meine schwester kristin raus an die
lara die sagt kiki richtig lecker
probleme weil sich das grab geholt hatte
nach der schule und dann hat dieses
gegessen vor mir und das so lecker aus
und war schon zu opfern
dann habe ich probiert das war echt
lecker handelt ist das ist noch nicht
probiert was ja nicht dabei bist du ja
wir haben also darauf gefunden das war
so ein mega fluffige hefeteig mit zimt
zucker und dann ist man das mit so nem
frosting was illegal
ja das team aber mega süß mal gucken wir
ob ich das vielleicht umwandle aber
zeige ich euch erst mal wie ihr das
risiko sie zu hause alleine machen könnt
und zwar habe ich hier ganz normales
mail das ist typ 405 das was ihr so
kennt weizenmehl und da gebe ich jetzt
trockenhefe rein ganzes genauen
mengenangaben stehen wie immer hier
unten in der video beschreibung einmal
trockenhefe rein ganze frühere ich jetzt
da gebe ich dann noch ein bisschen
puderzucker dazu eine prise salz die
krise sei zwar noch einmal den süßen
geschmack und anschließend stehen wir
nur mulde geben da geschmolzene butter
reihen lauwarme milch und ein ei und
wird dass wir den sauberen händen
verknetet
[Musik]
für den hefeteig habe ich jetzt noch 3
minuten auf der sauberen arbeitsfläche
geknetet und dann merkt ja auch schon
wenn er so weit ist wichtig ist
beherzigt meinem tipp und gebt immer
nach und nach das mehl dazu weil je
nachdem wie groß das ei ist es gibt der
größe s m oder l hawesko m verwendet er
brauchte eben mehr oder weniger mehl und
jetzt einfach zu nah kugel rolle es
macht ihr am besten indem ihr hier
einmal die enden immer in die mitte
drückt einmal umdrehen und so ein paar
mal auf der arbeitsfläche im kreis
drehen und jetzt schnappt ihr euch euer
backblech will das nachsitzen nicht in
der schüssel gehen sondern direkt das
backblech stoppen
ein back up oben drauf und dann den
hefeteig darauf legen und so lassen wir
das ganze zugedeckt rund 30 bis 45
minuten ich habe jetzt zeit ich lasse es
540 minuten gehen wenn ihr keine zeit
hat dann reichen auch 30 minuten
ach so und wir fahren jetzt haben sonne
in der zeit okay was geht's gut ich war
[Musik]
das will ich wieder zu hause und so
sieht das original aus sehr klein ist
mir aufgefallen ich hatte das viel
größer in erinnerung
auf jeden fall ist eine ordentliche
portion zimt zucker auf das machen wir
jetzt auch unser tag gesetzt schön
aufgegangen und wenn ihr das genauso
groß haben welche betriebe so klein über
dominos da nimmt einfach die hälfte des
rezepts verändert sich dann auch an der
backzeit nichts abbruch pro backofen
habe ich auf 180 grad ober und unter ist
jetzt vor geheilt ist es ganz wichtig
dass der ofen vorgeheizt ist jetzt nimmt
ihr euch die hände und drückst dem tag
einfach runter und drückt ihn quasi in
form
[Musik]
als nächstes verstreichen wir
geschmolzene butter auf dem brot und das
hilft erstens beim geschmack butter ist
der geschmacksträger zwei fürs aussehen
das kriegt ne schöne bräune und drittens
haftet jetzt unser zimt zucker besser
dran und für zug nimmt euch wie der name
schon sagt ganz einfach zucker rückgangs
im zimt ein und jetzt verteidigt das auf
der geschmolzene butter
[Musik]
so jetzt wird das sind brad noch
unterteilt und zwar in acht streifen das
ist einmal in der mitte durchschneiden
und dann links und rechts jeweils
zweimal durchschneiden und dann haben
wir acht ihr könnt auch zehn oder zwölf
machen es nicht so schlimm
[Musik]
und jetzt wandert in den backofen wie
gesagt ganz wichtig vorgeheizt 180 grad
ober unterhitze bis es richtig schön
goldbraun ist und wir kümmern uns in der
zwischenzeit um das frosting so hier
drin befindet sich das frosting
beziehungsweise das kriegt man immer mit
dazu nicht auch schon probiert es
schmeckt echt mega süß ist eine mega
süße masse und in den zutaten steht da
ist ein bisschen zitronensäure drin und
ein bisschen vanille aroma vanille aroma
wisst ihr ja schlecht immer mega
künstliche überhaupt nicht gut daher
nehme ich natürlich wenn ihre extrakte
könntet alternativ auch eine
vanilleschote nehmen also das mag und
was ich nehme ist eine basis aus doppel
ram frischkäse und puderzucker und das
führe ich jetzt erstmal gibt da schon
direkt also ein spritzer zitronensaft
rein und verdünnen dass mit milch und
anschließend kommt dann das kleine extra
dazu
[Musik]
also das ist mein fertige sizing
natürlich ist es nicht schön weiß wie
das original von domino's weil ich habe
jetzt hier keine keine
konservierungsstoffe keine
verdickungsmittel ich habe hier
natürlich echte vanille drin und das
macht es dann auch im geschmack
bemerkbar hier nochmal zum vergleich
also das ist natürlich nicht ja
natürlich
und deswegen gehe jedoch davon aus dass
das was ich jetzt hier zubereitet habe
natürlich besser schmeckt stimmt immer
so arrogant manche das so gar nicht da
mittlerweile sind dessen sind die
zutaten den unterschied machen natürlich
aber ich bin trotzdem gespannt welches
brot schmeckt ist nämlich auch ein paar
minuten fertig
[Musik]
ok haben so und ich haben wir gar schon
party gemacht so lecker schmeckt wir
feiern das einfach so vor allerdings
sehr schnell aber auch wenig zutaten
er hat mit alles da also nichts bildet
und das gute ist kaum ruhig näher ran
das ist mega soft datei zum glück nicht
zu dick ausgeräumt und es wird sehr
schwer im magen liegen und die kruste
hier oben bist total krost also hier
oben sehr knusprig und hier total weich
und dann müsst ihr das in das eis im
dicken ich demonstriere das mal so
richtig schön rein tippen kann dann
einfach genießen also dass hier das sind
im android mit dem eis sehen und dann
einfach eine geile netflix serie und ist
perfekt also macht es unbedingt nach
schreibt mir wie es euch gefallen hat
und ganz ganz wichtig schreibt mir in
die kommentare welches rezept ich als
nächstes nach machen soll
kennt ihr vielleicht noch irgendein
original aus irgend einem ladenlokal was
ich unbedingt mal nachmachen soll dann
schreibt es mir rein und dann kümmere
ich mich darum dass es kondition und das
o bezahlte werbung keine kooperation
ansonsten
lasst uns einfach in den kommentaren
schreibt abonniert meinen kanal ist auch
komplett kostenlos dann verpasst er auch
solch genialen rezepte nicht mehr und
dann sehen wir uns wenn man im nächsten
rezept video oder bei meinem nächsten
blog cherokee
[Musik]